sometimes people want creamier things
and sometimes people want like a is it
good
did you get that I almost hurt oh hi
Tiffany young I have Evan here because
he wants to get to like ice cream I
never had any like good ice cream before
in my life I just don't like sweet stuff
I don't like sweet things everybody
watching is judging you hard we're gonna
be going to some of the highest rated
ice cream places in LA according to Yelp
so yeah I am an ice cream fanatic I like
all the ice cream stores cuz I have a
favorite at each store so it's like okay
I'm feeling like Cap'n Crunch ice cream
today
what kind of Cap'n Crunch ice cream I am
your ice cream Bible
[Music]
we are now at our first location milk
ice cream parlor they're very famous for
their ice cream macaroon Becker's is
always pronounced it macaroons macaroon
yeah okay I think I have some street
cred with macarons another famous piece
red velvet cookies for any couple
Sophie's you can create an ice cream
sandwich one of my favorite ice cream
are the tighty whities great I always
get the banana split
I mean come on there's like Nutella
coffee coffee blood orange sorbet mint
and chip limesurvey Thai tea you name it
and you want to go for the banana split
do you own this place I know I can work
here I want to try to sandwich like a
you don't recommend your face tells me
think about it it's like would you want
Thai tea we fight pretty couples and
like you know I mean you have to be
smart okay I like mint ooh I love mint
chip I'd like just honesty it just
tastes like toothpaste it might be a
little weird but I'd like to taste up to
the Beast isn't that overpowering no I
guess not
[Music]
it's not that sweet it's not that sweet
that's why it's so good this is my
absolute favorite I mean who doesn't
like fruity pebbles if you don't like
fruity pebbles I questioned you Kendrick
Lamar likes fruity pebbles
too much flavor going on for me and then
when you want just like the original and
you want the og stuff you should get
this this light is great I was never
imagining type 2 with an ice cream and
always we always drink it as a team I
would put it on the inside like what do
you mean like the bottom because it's
flat come on
[Music]
we're here at Swami Swami in k-town
represent my first time here you like
soft-serve yes I do
so you can choose whether you want it on
a bouncer
I don't think viewers what know what be
rolls and you can pick your billion oh
my god good cheese ready Nutella this is
like the prettiest sprinkle this is like
it looks like Gucci it's so good oh joy
macho yes that's really good
it's pretty deep huh but it's not like
too heavy where it's the teen and make
sure like throat kind of hurt I think
for a black sesame SEC we can't forget
it is what I heard
sound like artificial super yeah I think
black sesame has a specific vine people
like you like you like it
sorry Joe for really good places with it
put the filling that's so good Oh guilty
pleasure for sure I have my makeup
artist he's like eight fruity
[Music]
we are finally at salt & straw on
Larchmont I bring my bandmates here all
the time not only do they have freely
really fancy and sophisticated lead
crafted flavors they have a monthly
flavour what I love about going to salt
& straw is that when you come out your
hair smells like you feel very very like
cute I am ready to feel cute yeah
tonight try do you want to try honey
lavender as well that's what it like
there so soon it tastes like a really
really good hand so I want the birthday
cake in blackberries which is like which
is like a July special there is a pole
at the end of the year so that they can
bring back certain Foley
I went hard on that gingerbread cookie
dough and they never came back if y'all
are watching help me vote for this
gingerbread cookie go back for the
summer okay
support that flavor it's just like the
fun part of it and you really become a
fan so I got honey lavender which is a
signature flavor I've never tasted any
much anything like this tastes exactly
like how it smells if that makes sense
yeah which is great texture and the
flavor and the temperature everything is
just like y'all getting this on camera
he's a fan I think that was it it wasn't
really anybody that was just like all
right we got to take you to some ice
cream store
I think parlours excuse me heaven try
some bunch of stuff
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so describe here that was my
part